because our schools namesakes Andrew
Carnegie and Andrew Mellon were of
Scottish ancestry were really proud of
our Scot
heritage here at Carnegie Mellon some of
the more poignant examples include our
schools adopted colors the Carnegie
family plaid our school emblem which is
the thistle and that's the national
emblem of Scotland our team name here is
the Tartans Tartans just a specific
pattern of plaid that's adopted by the
various clans of Scotland our official
mascot is the Scottish terrier our
school offers a degree in bagpipe
performance and our Schools marching
band the kiltie band does march in the
full Scottish regalia at football games
kilts and all and they're affectionately
known as the band without pants